writers are just some of my favorite
people writers living in dead you know
I'm I am who I am because of writers and
80 of what I love about our culture
comes from writers never mind the thing
that I do for a living I think we don't
really believe that a robot can
can write something that will be as
compelling as what a human being could
write in the same way uh
uh with all the new technology you know
you can bring Marilyn Monroe back from
the grave or Gary Cooper or Judy Garland
but of course it's not them it's a it's
a synthetic version of them and a
synthetic version of um
of writing or acting is never going to
be alive or unexpected